le dernier épisode de game of thrones
toutes saisons confondues sort dans
quelques jours et je n'en peux plus de
me taire je suis un énorme fan de la
série et je pense la maîtrise et presque
autant que l'univers du mc eu
il l'a clairement y avoir un avant et un
après game of thrones nous parlons de la
série qui aura marqué toute une
génération
je pensais attendre la fin de la saison
pour vous en parler de la série car oui
je ferai d'autres vidéos sur game of
thrones un peu philosophique en quelque
sorte mais je souhaite réellement parler
du dénouement final
bref la fin je vous propose dans cette
vidéo une analyse 100% personnel de ce
qui va arriver dans le dernier épisode
n'hésite pas à laisser un pouce bleus et
partager ta propre vision en commentaire
sur ce commençons ça y est nous avons
enfin toutes les cartes en main pour
définir la potentielle fin de la série
par où commencer il ya trop de choses à
dire biya de vagues daenerys sera très
certainement le point central de ce
dernier épisode la reine des dragons est
aujourd'hui l'antagoniste de la série et
malheureusement cela va signer son arrêt
de mort
en revenant sur l'épisode 5 il ya une
chose frappante à souligner c'est que
nous ne sommes plus face à daenerys mais
un dragon dans la mise en scène durant
la bataille nous voyons daenerys
seulement lorsqu elle doute de cramer
port réal ou plus exactement king's
landing
une fois ces décisions prises le dragon
qui est en elle prend le dessus et c'est
comme si elle avait fusionné avec drogon
daenerys n'est plus qu'un dragon en
colère qui a effacé toute son humanité
elle a ses raisons de par ses gènes pour
certains mais pour moi un daenerys a
laissé éclater sa colère par rapport aux
trahisons à la mort de ses alliés la
perte de l'amour de john daenerys a
besoin d'être canalisé est le seul
rempart entre elle et le burn out lui a
tourné le dos une nouvelle fois je cite
la peur suffira
elles possèdent toutes les raisons de
détruire port réal et le peuple du nord
aussi néanmoins revenons à l'épisode 6
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
daenerys a dévoilé sa face cachée au
point que même sort si fait pâle figure
à côté et je pense très sincèrement
qu'elle ne va pas s'arrêter à king's
landing comme montré dans le preview du
dernier épisode daenerys et seul entouré
d'autres acquis et des immaculés
john n'est pas à ses côtés quirion non
plus daenerys n'a plus besoin d'alliés
seulement de son armée et son dragon
je le répète la peur suffira cela
explique l'engouement que font preuve
les d'autres acquis comme un conseil de
guerre
comme quoi la guerre n'est pas finie et
daenerys compte conquérir tous westeros
le peuple du nord n'est d'ailleurs pas
présent et a même fui la ville
et justement en parlant du nord je pense
très sincèrement que le prochain but de
daenerys et de tuer sansa qui est devenu
la personne en qui elle voue une haine
infinie notamment à cause du secret
révélé une haine démontré par le côté
extrême de daenerys a affirmé que c'est
sans doute ça qui a tué varices au même
titre qu elle même malheureusement
daenerys devra très certainement mourir
étant donné qu'elle a atteint le point
de non retour et est considéré à l'heure
actuelle comme l'antagoniste principal
néanmoins ace que des ineris ira
réellement jusqu'au bout c'est là le
problème
si daenerys veut réussir et garder son
trône
elle devra tuer tous ceux qui se
mettront sur son passage et c'est là que
la nouvelle reine de westeros pourraient
faillir montrer de nouveau sa part
d'humanité
son point faible et se faire avoir là
dessus on parle de daenerys mais étant
donné que nous sommes sur le dernier
épisode de goat nous allons très
certainement revoir la totalité des
personnages encore vivant et où les
adieux n'ont pas été fait arias sera le
second point important de cet épisode je
vous le mets en mille et vous avez tous
pensé arias va vouloir tuer daenerys
elle ne lui a jamais fait confiance et
elle va vouloir venger les milliers
d'innocents tués durant le massacre
nous la voyons d'ailleurs avec un regard
empli de détermination caché dans la
foule des d'autres acquis cependant
arias et le gros hic pour moi de cet
épisode final nous sommes actuellement
sur un personnage qui a tué le roi de la
nuit
et ne cesse de nous prouver sa puissance
mais ne serait-ce pas gros et trop
évident que cette dernière tu daenerys
le problème pour moi est la symbolique
du cheval blanc et celui du maître de la
lumière
arias est comme une sorte d'élu est
justement le cheval blanc qui lui
apparaît pourraient être envoyés par
brad lui même mais
et pour moi je vois la symbolique du
cavalier de l'apocalypse la mort
chevauchant un cheval blanc
arias prend beaucoup de temps à l'écran
sur l'épisode 5 à nous montrer sa survie
au milieu de la destruction de king's
landing et c'est très étrange que ce
soit souligné à ce point surtout par
rapport aux innocents comme vous avez dû
le remarquer arias essaie d'aider une
jeune mère avec son enfant que nous
voyons depuis le début de l'épisode
et que fait arias sans le vouloir eh
bien elle mène ces innocents à la mort
comme si peu importe ce que arias fait
où elle va la mort arrive à rien et pour
moi le dernier symbole encore actif du
côté mystique de game of thrones alors
est ce que les scénaristes irons
jusqu'au bout en démontrant qu'elle est
la mort elle même ou bien se fera t-elle
stoppé par daenerys quoi qu'il en soit
l'une des deux va mourir si ce n'est les
deux mais qui va s'asseoir sur le trône
de fer daenerys il sera sur une très
courte durée alors qui prendra sa
succession
pour moi il y a quatre options possibles
je garde en tête que john pourrait s'y
asseoir depuis le début de la saison
john nous est montrée comme celui qui ne
veut pas avoir le trône cela en devient
même redondant
malgré ça varicent a obligatoirement
réussi à envoyer quelques messages avant
sa mort de plus en plus de monde sont au
courant et john pourrait devenir le roi
des sept couronnes malgré lui après la
mort de daenerys et les excuses du
cheese my queen ne marchera plus je
pencherais même sur un combat entre john
et un ver gris prête à tout pour
défendre daenerys bref
néanmoins si john survie il se peut que
ce dernier se retire dans le nord pour
rejoindre les sauvageons je le pense et
dans ce cas sans que ça pourrait être
une prétendante
après tout la série a commencé avec les
stars qu elle se finira avec les stark
la troisième option serait gay n'dri
cette idée ne vient pas de moi mais est
extrêmement bonnes pour la résumer
guesnerie est le dernier baratheon et
pour boucler la boucle tyrion lannister
tuerait daenerys la reine targaryen
comme le fils jamie par le passé avec le
roi fou et du coup un baratheon comme
robert à l'époque finirait sur le trône
ce qui me pose problème néanmoins et le
fait que thirion tu daenerys je suis
désolé pour vous mais
pour moi thirion va mourir dans ce
dernier épisode le personnage esquive la
mort depuis la saison 4 au moins quoi de
plus ironique pour ce personnage autant
apprécié des fans de mourir au dernier
épisode de la série à la porte du
nouveau monde
thirion dans le preview semble se
rapprocher de l'endroit où se trouve
daenerys avec une peur grandissante
le personnage a commis la trahison et va
de déception en déception par rapport à
la reine nous le voyons seul approchez
pas à pas loin de davos et john il était
même prêt à sacrifier sa vie dans
l'épisode 5
pour moi cela veut tout dire sans
oublier la problématique debron à
l'heure actuelle vu le point de non
retour de daenerys thirion ne pourra pas
tenir sa parole et léguer au jardin
c'est clair et net
et enfin quatrième option personnes sur
le trône et retour à l'époque dc3 de
westeros la symbolique de la destruction
de king's landing dans l'épisode 5
indique clairement qu'un nouveau monde
va être bâti ainsi qu'une nouvelle
capitale détruire le trône signifierait
la fin ultime du jeu de pouvoir qui est
la base de game of thrones ce serait la
fin la plus logique
petit bonus pour moi drogon se laissera
mourir suite à la mort de daenerys où
sera relâché en quelque sorte et partira
il est impossible de le tuer dans tous
les cas malgré tout ce qu'on peut
reprocher à cette saison 8 nous allons
avoir affaire à l'épisode qui je pense
sera le plus dur et le plus lourd
encaissé de la série c'est dur de
réaliser que nous sommes à la fin de
game of thrones
je ne parle pas forcément de branne
allez savoir pourquoi je vous avoue que
le personnage pour moi a perdu son
importance par le biais de l'épisode 3
mai bran sera bel et bien présent
attendez vous à le revoir
nous reparlerons de lui et du roi de la
nuit dans une prochaine vidéo
j'ai vraiment l'impression que götze va
se finir comme star wars
je me demande bien ce que les
scénaristes nous prépare je commence
sérieusement à être habitué d'être
surpris à chaque épisode
j'espère en tout cas que ma vidéo vous
aura plu gauthé réellement un pilier du
cinéma pour moi et je suis désolé
d'avoir six tarder pour en parler merci
à ceux qui laisseront un pouce bleus et
qui s'abonneront la prochaine fois que
nous nous reverrons ce sera pour le
poste goat et plus rien ne sera pareil
cette et argo rock et que le liner ce
soit avec vous
[Musique]